Can you tell us what it was like
having that many folks there,
and sleepy folks and people that
needed just comfort and how you
dealt with it?
>> It was absolutely crazy
having so many people from so
many different nationalities in
one room.
I think a lot of people think it
was our local patrons and guests
stuck here.
There was not more than my
left-hand man and right-hand man
here that were local, and the
rest were out of Canada, out of
state and from around the
country.
They came together and they were
washing dishes and bussing
tables.
It was a sight like no other.
As you said, we are -- it's old,
and we have a dining room that
can accommodate approximately
100 people, and we brought in
115 people.
>> Truly, you likely saved
peoples' lives.
We are seeing the result of the
cold temperatures and people
being stuck in cars.
Your Facebook page is covered
with people who are so so
thankful because of what you
did, like this one from Lynn
becca.
She writes the true meaning of
Christmas.
People from all over, different
backgrounds and different
beliefs but united as one.
Nothing but smiles, no worries
in that very moment.
Rested, full bellies, warm and
sheltered thanks to the great
community members of Alabama
hotel.
This is seriously the best
blizzard of 2022 story ever.
How did you spend the two days
yourself?
Please, tell me the names of the
folks that were there to help
everybody feel comfortable?
>> So I spent the two days
awake, very awake, and tired at
times.
Craig Alexander from the Alabama
holly farms across the street
was here with me.
He was just trudging through the
snow back and forth to the meat
market, bringing us more food
when it was necessary.
I had Brian from B & K
construction, and he was one of
the locals that was here all the
time and his daughter was
involved in an accident up the
street that brought him in, and
little did he know he would be
working side by side with me for
48 hours.
>> That's really beautiful to
here.
>> The whole community, the
women just a few doors down,
came through the snow pulling
two sleighs of blankets, pillows
and air mattresses.
The community members that
dropped off Christmas presents
so these children had something
to open up on Christmas morning.
Just crazy, crazy, absolutely
crazy how everybody came
together.
This place ran like a smooth
oiled machine.
We served a lot of food, and not
only did we serve a lot of food,
we served about 60 pounds of
prime rib, and these folks had a
prime rib dinner on Christmas
eve.
That's thanks to Bonnie, and I
said I fed these guys so much
food, and she said break out the
prime rib, so we did.
>> That is so beautiful.
Just lovely to hear people
coming together like that in a
place where we're kind of
fractured on some levels.
I wanted to quickly ask you
about a father named Nico, and
he was stunned and said you
saved the lives of he and his
family.
Tell us stories about some of
the people and what they were
facing and why they ended up
there at your restaurant?
>> So it's my understanding that
most of these people ended up at
the restaurant because they were
on the thruway and the thruway
was closed and they got off and
most of them were driving
towards Canada, and some folks
just ended out front because
there was a sign that said
hotel, and some used Google and
it said we were a hotel offering
rooms.
They just started pouring in.
I don't know what else to say.
They just started pouring in and
it started with one or two
people, and then a few minutes
later it was 10 people, 15
people.
And a lot of these people were
rescued off the side of the road
by the state police, and the
transportation department, and
helping to get people here and I
do -- I do believe we saved a life or two.